According to an 1894 researched report, the
earliest effort to create any sort of post
office in the colonies was in 1639 by the
Massachusetts General Court when a tavern
in Boston owned by Richard Fairbanks was designated
to be the first post office.
This was in keeping with the European tradition
of coffee houses and taverns being mailing
centers.
The first post messenger may have started
in 1672 or 1673 with instructions to “behave
civilly” and to mark trees so other travelers
would know where they are going.
Around that same time, a monthly mail route
was set up between New York and Boston.
It became known as the Old Boston Post Road,
which is still part of today’s US Route
1.
It was two decades later when the King and
Queen of England granted Thomas Neal – a
man who lived in England and had never been
to the colonies – a 21-year grant to establish
offices that received and dispatched letters
and to set postal rates.
This created a centralized postal organization
that helped foster a more efficient means
of correspondence between colonies and to
encourage trade and commerce.
In 1707, the British crown bought out the
grant and brought the system under their control.
By the 1730s, the colonies’ postal system
was pretty well-established.
Mail carriers from Maine to Georgia (in the
South, often slaves) trudge across the rapidly
expanding American land to deliver letters,
correspondence and contracts.
The position of postmaster had become a posh,
but important one.
They were in charge of the postal rates, the
exact routes taken by carriers and the locations
of post offices.
In addition, each city had its own postmaster,
which carried out many of the same responsibilities
as the postmaster general but on a regional
basis.
In 1737, a young 31-year old publisher, printer
and well-known civic leader was appointed
to be the postmaster of Philadelphia, then
one of the most populous cities in the colonies.
His name was Benjamin Franklin.
For 16 years, Franklin used his influence
and power as the city’s postmaster general
to increase the circulation of his Pennsylvania
Gazette by decreasing newspaper mailing rates.
While this certainly does seem like a conflict
of interest, this practice was actually encouraged.
In 1753, when the postmaster died from a long-standing
illness, Franklin was promoted to be the joint
postmaster general – along with William
Hunter from Williamsburg – for all the colonies.
In that position, Franklin helped modernized
the post office.
His first order of business was to set out
on a long tour in order to inspect the post
offices and survey the routes used.
He concluded that more efficient routes needed
to be taken, so he oversaw the marking and
laying out of these new roads.
Next, he put in place night service between
Philadelphia and New York to improve the speed
of mail delivery.
Then, he installed a standardized system of
postal rates based on weight and distance
of delivery.
He also created a regular schedule for mail
by boat from the colonies to the homeland
of England.
By 1760, and for the first time in over a
century of operating, the colonies’ post
office turned a profit for the British crown.
However, as the clouds of revolution approached,
it became clear where Franklin’s allegiances
laid – with the colonies.
Despite Franklin’s considerable and notable
work for England, he was dismissed in 1774
as postmaster general for being a colonial
sympathizer.
Franklin’s career being in charge of mail
wasn’t over, however.
Within weeks of the Battles of Lexington and
Concord setting off the American Revolution,
the Second Continental Congress met and Pennsylvania’s
representative was Franklin.
At the time, William Goddard was running the
Constitutional Post, a mail service financed
by newspaper subscribers.
The main purpose was to disseminate information
about the rebellion and to connect Congress
to the armies.
Because of this, mail carriers had to swear
to secure their missives under lock and key
in case the British attempted to take them.
In July 1775, citing his experience, Franklin
was named the Postmaster General of the Constitutional
Post.
Since he was in that position when the Declaration
of Independence was written, he earns the
distinction of being the first Postmaster
General in US history.
However, he would resign in November of that
year in order to become a delegate to Paris
to gain their support for the war.
Six years later, the Articles of Confederation
gave the federal government the right to establish
and regulate post offices.
Revisions and ordinances continued to add
shape to the post office’s duties, restrictions
and rules, including one that said the federal
government had a monopoly on delivering the
mail.
The Constitution – officially ratified in
June 1788 – gave many of the same powers
to the post office that the AOC did.
By 1790, a United States population of almost
four million was served by 75 Post Offices
and approximately 2,400 miles of post roads.
Two years later, in 1792, America’s first
president signed the Postal Service Act, creating
the modern United States Postal Service.
And the rest, as they say, is history.